Last week I told you that more and more Republicans
are just quitting politics in the Trump era.
Some don't want to be Republicans under Trump.
Some are worried that they're going to lose
their reelections and want to retire and save
some face even in historically pretty reliably
red districts.
And last week I told you about a few of them.
We had Republican Congressman Mike mcconaughey.
I told you about Paul Mitchell, who's bailing
Pete Olson, Martha Roby, rob Bishop, Republican
members of Congress.
I've already spoken previously about Senator
Jeff Flake.
Senator Jeff Flake was a Republican from the
state of Arizona.
He ended up bailing pretty clearly because
of a disgust with the Republican Party under
Donald Trump.
That was a seat.
Democrats were able to take.
Kirsten Sinema ultimately won Jeff Flake seats.
So this stuff matters and there's now two
more.
Okay.
Congressman Kenny Marchant is saying bye bye
and quitting.
This is in Texas and this one matters sort
of extra because this is the Dallas area.
The 24th Congressional District Democrats
have done better and better in recent election
cycles.
There were some pre 2018 election cycles where
Democrats got between 32 and 37 ish percent
of the vote in the 24th district in 2018 it
was closer than it had been in a really long
time.
Jan McDowell, the Democratic challenger, received
47% of the vote, barely losing two the Republican
Kenny Marshawn, so that's a great district
for Democrats to target.
Democrats are targeting it.
This is not an out of reach district that
will obviously go to a Republican.
That's really good news.
We then also learned a few days ago that we'll
heard HRD also from Texas is quitting.
He will not be seeking reelection.
His district is a border district.
He also won reelection by fewer than five
points in 2018 and in that district it worked
out to just a few hundred votes based on voter
turnout.
So that's another district that will be open
and we'll be in play for Democrats in 2020
so there are now 12 Republicans, 12 republicans
who are not running for reelection in 2020
this is very good for Democrats.
Incumbent Republicans are much more likely
to be helped by a republican president running
for reelection.
That's Trump in 2020 open seats are more likely
to be fights when you have two new challengers
or candidates, I guess we would call them.
The Senate reality remains that it's very
unlikely Democrats are going to take the Senate
in 2020 I got some interesting emails, so
I've been saying for months now, as you may
know or you may not know, and that's okay.
There are a hundred senators and a third of
them are up for reelection every two years
since they are six year terms.
It just so happens that the slate of senators
up for reelection in 2020 is not favorable
to Democrats.
I don't really see a path for Democrats to
take the Senate in 2020 last week, I asked
for people to write in if you thought there
was a way for Democrats to take the Senate,
and I got a couple of emails from people talking
about, uh, well if Doug Jones is able to retain
his seat in um, uh, Alabama and then in Colorado,
uh, the election goes one way and a couple
of people put together scenarios, but they
are definitely uphill battles.
But if in the house we see an expanded Democratic
majority in 2018 thanks in part to some of
these Republicans quitting a bigger house,
majority sets up Democrats to be better positioned
in 2022 for the Senate showdown, we're Democrats
actually could retake control of the Senate,
which of course would be massive.
If Trump is removed in 2020 Democrats, expand
control of the house in 2020 and then take
control in 2022 that period between January
of 2023 and January of 2025 could be massive
in terms of actual positive possible advancements
for the progressive left in the United States.
That's why this stuff matters.
This is why midterms matter.
Republicans are now on the defensive after
losing the house in 2018 they're in danger
of falling even further behind.
They are now potentially endangering their
Senate majority just two years later and Texas
is increasingly a target.
No longer solid red, but we've got to run
these elections correctly every single one.
Now I'll, I will have more detailed reports
for you about particular districts to target.
We actually are starting to line up some interviews
with some interesting district level races,
House races for 2020 I'll be talking about
what you can do as we get closer to 2020 for
maximum impact focusing not on really safe
blue districts but on the ones that we might
be able to take from Republicans.
And we will also be talking about this extensively
in the context of Democrats have to get it
together at the local politics level.
I've been talking about this for years.
Democrats just aren't good at a lot of things.
One is local grassroots races, a state legislatures,
state senates as an example.
We will be talking about that because that
matters as well.
It's not just representatives in Washington
that determine the political slant of the
country and within states, but it's what's
happening in state legislatures as well.
So we're going to talk about that.
We're also going to talk more broadly about
continuing to talk about the other areas that
really impact this gerrymandering and districting
and that relates to the census, voter suppression,
so on and so on.
You probably know all of that.
Uh, one of the things I would love to talk
about tonight during my live stream on twitch
at 6:30 PM eastern time, which I hope you'll
join me for a our specific races that you're
paying attention to.
Okay.
So I hope you'll join me this evening.
6:30 PM eastern twitch.tv/david Pacman.
Make sure you're following me there.
Make sure if you have Amazon prime that you
sign up for three with twitch prime.
We get paid at cost, nothing.
And I'll meet you there.
6:30 PM eastern deceived to get to particular